merci d'être avec nous il est 20h20 on
est en direct et c'est touche pas mon
poste alors là je vous le dis gros gros
programme on va parler de Stéphane Plaza
dans un instant avec deux nouvell B de
nouveaux témoins exclusifs pour TPMP
vous allez voir deux témoignages
exclusifs qui vont dans le même sens
vous verrez ça dans un instant on aura
également d'incroyables révélations dans
l'affaire Émile vous savez ce petit
garçon de 2 ans et qui avait disparu et
l'enquête avance à grand pas mont Gilou
oui absolument et on aura aussi euh
Michel marie aussi nous parle de du
meurtre de Justine Virac vous rappelez
Justine verac on Rapp ou pas il va nous
rappeler cette affaire et vous allez
voir là euh vous allez réagir là-dessus
parce que G je crois que tu es un petit
peu au courant il y a eu un énorme coup
de théâtre ouais euh on va d'abord
parler Jean-Michel vous vouliz dire
quelque chose on parlait il y a un
instant juste avant la pause voilà de de
de
Maiva qui décide un contrat parce
qu'elle disait que ses engagements étai
valent plus qu'un contrat donc je
voulais savoir Gill tout simplement puis
que tu veux tapplaudis à cette cette
cette décision est-ce que tu as des
copains de confession juif est-ce que
tes engagements du coup vont t'obliger à
rompre moi déjà est-ce que tes
engagements sont au dessus de ton amitié
avec eux par que je je je mais il a pas
dit qui j'ai non c'est pas tout à fait
ouais si t
engagement jeis être clair d'abord je
vais vous répondre je ne suis pas
sédiicieux j'appelle pas la guerre
civile je vis le redire parce qu'on a
l'impression avec vous que j'appelle à
la séparation des uns et des autres ou
ben je préfère le dire deuxième chose
moi ce que j'aime bien chez ma vagenam
c'est pas ses engagements c'est c'est
pas ses déclarations c'est je ne suis
pas d'accord je rond et en ce moment
vous faites de l' devra faire Faou vous
fait vous faites de l'angélisme je
trouve on pr mais oui mais moi aussi je
prend alors voilà là vous recommencez
moi aussi je prendre la paix onend les
discussions sur les r non mais
laissez-moi juste finir sur les Ré
sociaux et aussi dans la vraie vie c'est
clivé vous pouvez le déplorer mais c'est
drapeau Palestine drapeau
d'israëlplore on l contre ça oui mais ça
existe donc je trouve que c'est normal
que des gens rompent économiquement moi
je ne le ferai sans doute pas je ne le
ferai pas mais je la comprends pouroi tu
ferais pas alors ça juste non mais c'est
ça en fait c'est c'est comme si tu poses
agile ta démission parce que cy est juif
par
exempleés arrê mais là non mais non mais
sppelle l'antisémi j'ai contre ça toute
ma vieain de dire tu es en train de dire
non attends je vais m'expliquer tu es en
train de dire que ces deux personnes tu
les encourages à ne plus travailler
ensemble parce qu'elles n'ont pas la
même je les encourage pas je les
comprends
tuendis com le
truc moi je suis pas d'accord avec cy
lundi on s'est frité il m'a laissé
m'exprimer on pas d'accord même sur sur
prix et je reste parce que moi j'estime
que
tout à fait
normal attendez attendez attendez
laissez parler arrêtez de tomber arrête
deber moi ici je peux m'exprimer
éminemment je suis pas d'accord parfois
je le dis je suis très bien ici très
heureux et après on a des débats
extrêmement clivés et moi je reste là
avec un immense plaisir et c'est tout à
fait normal je suis pas d'accord tout à
l'heure on a discuté sur quoi on était
pas d'accord déjà sur rien fait non
c'était sur ah oui tu avais pas tu avais
pas euh tu étais d'accord je sais plus
CIT sur le tweet non sur le tweet de
Mélenchon sur Y Bron P c'est ça abum
c'est ça tu comprenz aussi le tweet de
Mélenchon sur Y Bron P oui vous me
reprochiez de ne pas dire d'abord je
pense à yel Bron Pivet et cetera ok mais
ici on peut s'exprimer bah oui en toute
indépendance en toute liberté Cyril ne
sait jamais ce que je vais dire jamais
et je heureusement heureusement on
s'engueule et et c'est pareil pour tout
le
monde s vous plî plaî 2 minutes parce
que je vis parle à G de petit second
parce que j'ai vu plein de trucs aussi
plein d'articles g truc j'ai vu même des
gens qui sont
mêlés arrêtez g ça fait ça fait combien
de temps que tu es dans l'émission 10s
10 ans ça fait 10 ans qu'on se prend la
tête tous les jours surtout sur le prix
du Croissant prendre on va se prendre la
tête non mais c'est vrai ou
pas g c'est le seul que j'ai appelé ce
weekendutur donc voilà donc il faut
arrêter avec ça parce que y a j'ai vu
qui disaient oui g
humilié je peux vous dire qu'il est très
heureux ici et on se parle tout le temp
et Mo
iteme donc ça veut dire que MAA et Magal
ne peuvent pas se parler ell peuvent pas
faire comme vous en fait elles estim que
c'est impossible
donc sont dans les même position que
nous g et moi on pr avant tout la paix
elle aussi bien
entendu aussi mais je vous dire alors je
vous dire a deux il y a deux lectures il
y a la lecture qui parl pour la paix et
sur les réseaux soci je vous le jure et
là je prends la défense de personne
c'est la guerre je dis et ça il faut pas
faire comme si on le
voyait ici on la pai sur les réseaux
nous sur les réseaux il est sorti
comprenait la guerre justement je un
truc boycot boot je l'ai pas encore vu
le seule émission qui a été boycotté
pour l'instant c'est punaises de l mais
je vous le dis donc voilà donc j'ai pas
encore senti dans les audiences non mais
en plus nous je dire boycotte ou pas
boycotter PMP nous on est droit dans nos
bottes je vous le dis et on est très
heureux ici de preneer la paix tous les
soirs et Gilles c'est le seul endroit
ici de liberté ù Gill peut dire tout ce
qu'il veut je peux vous dire que dans
aucune émission Gilles Verdez pourrait
dire ce qu'il dit ici ça c'est sûr et
certain Gill c'est vrai ou pas pari je
trouve qu'au contraire dans dans
beaucoup d'émissions après pas toutes il
y a une pensée unique et j'ai dit j'ai
toujours dit que dans toute ma pas ma
carrière mais bon mon parcours
professionnel c'est là où j'ai été le
plus libre vous n'imaginez pas ce que on
vit ailleurs dans des
radio jamais je suis venu voir et
sachez-le jamais je suis venu voir Gill
à la fin d'une émission même quand on
s'est pris la tête très fort pour lui
dire un truc jamais de la vie le croise
en escalier parce qu'il part très vite
pour aller retrouver Fatou je pas encore
sorti du plateau et c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois je salut mon Gilou comme si
on avait rien mais comme si de rien é
c'est vraiment c'est la
règleement jamais y a un truc je sais
pas si vous avez vu ce truc là parce que
c'est bien qu'on en parle ce soir tiens
j'ai vu un truc passer genre boycotte t
P pourquoi JEE pas moi les réseau il
prennent des chiffres bidons ou oui ils
prennent des chiffres bidons et on sait
très bien que quand il y a du foot
pardon de le dire ce soir mais quand il
y a du foot c'est vrai qu'on voilà un pe
moin
bien donc il s'amuse à truquer les
chiffres et à dire bah regardez sur
ce je vais les arrêter tout de suite non
arrêz ni de trucquer les chiffres rien
du tout je vais vous dire les gars on
est jusqu'en 202 jus 2026 donc ceux qui
veulent regarder avec grand plaisir et
franchement merci d'être aussi nombreux
à nous regarder et merci pour tous les
messages moi je regarde surtout les
messages positifs et merci à vous pour
tous les messages positifs que nous
envoyez et ceux qui ne veulent pas
regarder on on comprend tout à fait on
leur en veut pas et il y a aucun
problème il y a plein d'autres
programmes très bien et sachez-le TPMP
là jusqu'en 2026 et TPMP fait une
rentrée voilà pour je vous le dis
historique en audience donc voilà c'est
grâce à vous aussi c'est grâce à vous
qui nous suivez donc il y a aucune
question là-dessus juste la vraie
question c'est parce que j'ai vu moi ce
qui m'a plus gêné c'est Gill et moi et
Gill et moi je vous le dis on a on n pas
d'accord ça fait 10 ans qu'on est pas
d'accord je crois qu'on a jamais été
d'accord sur sujet voilà mais Gill et
moi on se parle toujours au contraire et
on est pour le dialogue et pour on
s' je vous dire un truc et je pense que
Gill si demain je l'appelle je peux
avoir une énorme galère je peux vous
dire à 4h du matin j'ai perdu mon slip
ou un truc comme ça et ben c'est lui qui
vira m'aider et il sait que s'il
m'appelle il sait que je toujours là
pour déjà
fait a eu des problèmes et cetera il sa
que je suis toujours là pour lui qu'
peut toujours compter sur Mo sa que je
peux compter sur Luis vos équipes vous
avez toujours été là voilà et on sera
toujours là pour toi mon Gilou même si
on n pas d'accord sur plein de choses
moi je vois plein de gens qui me disent
je vous jure et ça ça aussi ça m'énerve
arrêtez je vois plein de gens qui me
disent il faut virer Gill Verdez non
mais on est où là on est où là il faut
virer Gill Verdez sachezle Gill ver ça
ressemble à Magalie et je vous dis c'est
comme t PMP jusqu'en 2026 Gill verd il
sera jamais viré voilà je vous le dis
parce que Gill
verd je dis voilà mais je te dis voilà
et il y a plein de gens qui m'appellent
non mais je te le dis Gill parce que on
n pas d'accord sur plein de trucs il a
plein il faut virer Gilles Verdez il y a
aussi plein de messages qui disent bravo
à ce que dit Gill s non mais parce que
moi je parle de moi de moi le ressenti
que j'ai parce qu'il y a plein de gens
qui me disent il faut que tu vires Gill
ver non mais on est fou quoi Gill Verdez
il est là et il sera là jusqu'en 2026
avec moi s'il est en disent il est
humilié mais on Sepe le chignon on adore
ça on revient tous les jours parce qu'on
adore ça seper le chignon on pas compris
on comprend que c'est sympa pour le
boycotte TPMP qui est symptomatique sur
le boycotte TPMP ici on pas boycotte non
mais les gens les gens qui on lancé
boycott TPMT on a parlé de toutes les
guerres ici depuis 3 4 ans l'Ukraine on
a parlé d'Ukraine on a donné notre avis
sur l'Ukraine comme on donne sur notre
avis là il a jamais eu de boycottte tpnp
jamais à chaque fois qu'on donne notre
avis sur l'actualité et sur des guerres
c'est malheureux on donne notre avis et
là pour vous dire qu'on est sur une
poudrière assise sur une poudrière c'est
que là les mecs te lancent des des
boycottes t PMP alors que c'est jamais
arrivé avant c'est quand même c'est
quand même assez curieux et c'est
tellement violent sur les réseaux
sociaux mais que même quand on est pour
la paix en fait et ben ça ne va pas même
si on mes deux drapeaux ça ne va pas
vous le dis ne vous ne vous dérangez pas
mais c'est des messages de haine et
cetera mê les gars je ne regarde rien je
vous dis je suis au padol toute la
journée non mais je vais vous dire les
seuls trucs que je regarde c'est la
limite les résultats de padle du
résultat du match à suc enri et et
parfois il me disent ouais tu as vu sur
les réseaux ou qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur
les réseaux donc voilà donc je vous dis
je ne regarde rien et je m'en tape
totalement et Gill tu le sais mon chéri
voilà donc tu sais moi je ne regarde
rienis et voilà non juste parfois il y a
des gens qui me disent faut virer Gill
verd voilà donc je vous confirme que
Gill verd sera avec nous jusqu'en 2026
il sera plus je pense plus longtemps
dans l'émission qu'avec Fatou
voilà par que là c'était parfait jusque
là cétait parfait la dernière FO sais le
problème que j'ai c'est que je dis
toujours ce que je pense trop c'est le
souci c'est le souci et et et je vous
dis ça moi je peux plus moi des guerres
là comme ça moi tous mes potes là nous
nous on parle pas de ça mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai moi moi je suis avec
tari toute la journée qui qui est mon
frère je avec je Rachid qui est mon
frère voilà mais vous croyez qu'on parle
de ça non mais on vrai qu'on parle de ça
au contraire on se dit comment on peut
avancer comment on peut faire la paix on
essaie de trouver des idées pour voir
comment on peut réunir peut-être un truc
un plateau euh voilà mais vous croyez
qu'on on se parle pas de ça nous ce
qu'on nous on est allergique à un seul
truc les cons c'est tout je vous dis
voilà le reste je vais vous dire voilà
plus qu'allergique et j'en vois beaucoup
sur les réseaux parce que parfois c'est
vrai que quand je veux regarder un
résultat de padle je tombe sur un truc
et je dis ah qui est con celui-ci voilà
voilà après voilà et puis des mecs qui
derrière ah j'ai tiens j'ai même vu un
mec là tiens fa quoi parce que tiens
comme ça je vous dis tout en direct il y
a un mec alerte info je sais pas si vous
avez vu il y a un truc c'est alerte info
c'est un site qui s'appelle alerte info
et le gars c'est lui qui a commencé à
mettre des fausses infos sur nous sur
les audiences et cetera alors ça a l'air
d'être un site sérieux c'est alerte info
le truc voilà je vous le dis et le gars
donc je il a il a tweeté lui-même là là
il y a 21 minutes ouis je jeis vou lire
son tweet s'appelle Moussa fondateur et
seul cm d'alerte info compte personnel
qui n'a rien à voir avec alerte info
mais bon c'est le fondateur cm d'alerte
info lui c'est son compte perso regardez
ce qu'il met sur son compte perso donc
Moussa cyil Hanouna on va t'apprendre
qui est qui ça va t'apprendre à faire le
voyou alors que tu es une voyelle oublie
pas que tu lécher le trou de Fiac d'un
chien il y a quelques années quoi donc
un gars d'alerte info donc me menace sur
Twitter non mais les gars donc c'est un
mec il a un site d'info et il vient
menacer sur ttter regarde t PMP c'est
bien quand voilà donc Moussa continue à
nous regarder et si tu veux venir ici
nous en parler moi avec plaisir moi si
il veut qu'on le reçoie franchement
Moussa il peut venir et avec grand
plaisir et on viendra il viendra
s'exliquer avec moi sur le plate moi
c'est avec grand plaisir vous savez
franchement je reçois tout le monde donc
Moussa tu es le bienvenu demain pour
m'expliquer ton tweet voilà comme ça bah
tu as invité dans l'émission bah demain
si tu vas être à la place de juste à
côté de Jean-Michel mer tu verras il est
très sympa on comprend pas tout ce qu'il
dit mais c'est sympa d'être à côté de
lui hein donc Moussa tu es invité
cordialement demain je t'attends parce
que faire le beau sur les réseaux et
mettre des fausses infos sur alerte info
c'est très bien mais si tu veux venir
ici bien sûr tu es le bienvenu on
t'attendra demain et t'inquiète pas ça
sera sympathique t'inquite pas non mais
c'est vrai ça se passera très bien on
parlera et vous allez voir VO du
dégueulasse de on s'est quitté tu ne
tromperas personne et c'est c'est quoi
ça veut dire quoi explique-toi enfin
c'est c'est il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
haine làdedans voilà exactement beaucoup
de haine là-dedans bah écoutez on espère
qu'il viendra exprimer sa haine ici sur
le plateau nous on reçoit toujours les
gens voilà et qui viennent s'expliquer
avec nous avec grand plaisir on va
parler de l'affaire Stéphane Plazza
tiens nouveau témoignage exclusif dans
tes PMP puis que